- Good morning everyone.
Welcome to Yale for the closing workshop
of the Understanding the
Nature of Inference Project.
I'm Priya Natarajan
an astrophysicist jointly appointed
in the departments of
astronomy and physics at Yale,
where I also serve as the current director
of Yale's flagship
interdisciplinary Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities.
As you are all probably aware,
this is an intellectual experiment,
although David Kaiser just reminded me
the likes of him and me should not be left
to do well near any
experimental equipment,
but real material equipment.
So this is an experiment
in crossing boundaries,
real and imagined amongst
intellectual disciplines
that are often unfortunately siloed
and do not speak to each other.
And it's an experiment
in learning new languages
and metaphors as well
as new ways of thinking,
probing and understanding
a really complex world.
It has probably not escaped you all
that even the terms causal
and inference to say
nothing of causal inference
means something completely different
in each of our disciplines.
At Yale, we decided to
take on this challenge
and explore how we could talk
and have an fruitful exchange of ideas
that disrupt tired old ways of thinking
and open up new arenas for
interdisciplinary engagement.
So here we are.
So our project thus far has
focused on deeply examining
the process of inference
of cause and effect across disciplines.
And our motivation has been
to understand this process
using various kinds of evidence
and data, conceptual modeling
and simulations as proxies
for controlled scientific experiments.
At this workshop,
we have assembled an
extraordinary group of scholars,
experts across different
intellectual fields
ranging from epidemiology,
anthropology, cosmology,
genetics, computer science,
mathematics to name a few,
as well as philosophers of
science who study the nature
of inference and causal relationships.
We look forward to
exploring the various kinds
of conceptual frameworks
used to distill the role
that modeling plays in
aiding the disentangling
of correlation and causation,
which is one of the
fundamental open questions
in epistemology today,
this distinction between
causation and correlation,
particularly amplified in
the data of big era, AI,
machine learning and so on.
So the production of new
knowledge is inevitably linked
to the understanding of cause and effect
and the underlying principles,
if any exists, that is,
that map between them.
And the study of causality
lies at the very core
of all scientific inquiry.
Sifting out causality is also
imperative when predictions
for future behavior of complex systems
under investigation or sought.
There are many approaches
to studying causation,
which we will get a glimpse
of in the next two days,
including probabilistic,
manipulative, counterfactual
and structural ones that
invariably comprise a set of tools,
very powerful tools that
will help us discriminate
between causal connections
and statistical associations.
Our multi-disciplinary
project thus far has included
a colloquium and a post
colloquium discussion series,
and this workshop is a
culmination of various teams
that we have engaged with over the course
of the last two and a half years.
Our work is supported
by the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities
at Yale, the Kempf Fund at Yale,
and the John Templeton Foundation.
I would like to thank
our entire core team,
Dr. Tahia Kamp, the executive
director of the Franke Program
for guiding all our activities thus far
and helping us shape
this two day workshop.
I wanna give a special
shout out to Larry Gladney,
our Dean of Science, who
is here in the audience.
Thank you so much Larry for coming.
And I want to thank all
our invited speakers,
some of whom have traveled far to be here
and for generously sharing
their ideas, being open
to sharing ideas with across
disciplinary audience.
And pretty much, you know, say thank you
to everyone in the audience
for participating in this
interdisciplinary adventure.
I'm really excited and look forward
to learning from everyone
over the next two days.
And without further
ado, let's get started.
Our first session is
themed around causation
and our opening speaker
is Samantha Kleinberg
and her talk is titled
Learning Causes and Using Them.
Thank you Samantha.
And the floor is yours.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks so much for having me.
Whoops, wrong microphone.
So I started getting
interested in causality
when I was a PhD student in 2006
and I was reading a lot of biology papers,
but there was something
sort of weird about them.
All these papers had causality
in the title and the abstract
and then there was not really
any discussion of causality
during the paper or
causality would be, you know,
coming up in the discussion
and throughout the paper
there'd be associations.
And so I was sort of wondering
where did the causality happen?
What do people mean by causes?
Recently I went back and
found a bunch of papers
that confirmed this anecdote.
84% of these studies
that one group looked at
that were just predictions in associations
mentioned causality somewhere.
Another one looked at where
the causality happened.
There's a sort of switching back and forth
between causal language
and non causal language.
Another one looked at,
this is my favorite 31%
that didn't really
actually have any causality
used misleading language, but
then also in their discussion
disavowed the causality.
And so they were sort
of selling the causality
in the title and the
abstract, but then saying,
actually we don't really have
any causal relationships.
So it's interesting that
causality kept coming up a lot,
but also there was this sort of shady,
do we have causes, do we don't?
Does it matter?
At the same time, people are
also saying things like this
that actually you don't
need causes, right?
You know, and this was a nice
quote telling the best story
about the research findings.
You don't need to say that X causes Y
and this is for epidemiological research.
And the authors agree,
we wanna prevent disease,
we wanna intervene.
Apparently causes are not
super helpful for that.
And also that we actually
can't even find causes,
we can't definitively claim causality.
And so that seemed really bad
given all the papers talking
about causality and
claiming to find causes.
As a computer scientist,
this came up a lot,
people saying don't worry about it, right?
If you're trying to make predictions
who caress why they work,
you only need to know
that your prediction does work.
And so maybe, you know, just
give up on this pursuit.
But to me it was more like this.
You know, if causality isn't so important,
why is everyone claiming we
have causal relationships
or trying to find causal relationships?
One might be everyone else is doing it.
And so if everyone else is
mentioning causal relationships,
maybe we should too.
Or there's some value in
causal relationships, right?
The same reason people lie
on dating profiles, right?
You lie about things that you
think other people care about
or that might make you more appealing
or make your research
more appealing, right?
And I think it's kind of the second one
that there is some value
in mentioning causes
and that's why people talk about them
and maybe exaggerate their findings.
So I was a computer scientist,
I guess I'm still sort
of a computer scientist at the time
because computational biology rejected me.
So my PhD was computer science.
And so I thought, okay, what
do computer scientists have
to say about causality?
And this is what that looked like.
And so this was causality
in computer science in 2006
was base nets and they
were generally very simple.
It was, you know, you have two variables,
how do we find causal
relationships between them?
It wasn't super satisfying for me
because I was interested in
problems that looked like this.
This is an actual patient
in the neuro ICU at Columbia
where I've collaborated
with people since 2010.
It's a super complex environment.
There's lots of things measured.
This is an advanced ICU that
actually stores all this data.
Other ICUs don't.
And so you just happen to
see things streaming by
in real time.
Maybe a nurse writes down
some of the variables,
numbers, maybe they don't.
I've worked with other ICUs
where records are still kept on paper
and scanned in as PDFs.
And so this is actually,
you know, cutting edge,
but it's a really complex
decision making problem.
And there's this tension between this is
what reality looks like for this problem.
And then we have our base
net with our two variables
and no timing or complexity
or, you know, interactions
between these variables.
But talking to the doctors,
it did seem they did want causes.
They weren't going to be
satisfied with predictions
and just knowing, you know,
this is what's going to
happen to the patient.
I also work on decision making problems
where patients are making choices.
Like in diabetes, it's not the doctor
helping you manage your
blood glucose every day.
It's you as an individual
having to do that.
And again, people don't
just want predictions.
And so I was satisfied that yes,
they actually do want
causal relationships.
They don't wanna know.
There's been a huge
history of alarms in ICUs
and usually that's
what the computer scientists
come along and provide.
There's alarms, lots of
bad things happen in ICU
can't do anything about a lot of them.
And so the doctors,
nurses get alarm fatigue
and start ignoring the alarms.
And then what ultimately
happens is they ignore ones
that they should have listened to
and in bad cases patients
have died as a result,
because most of the
alarms are not actionable
and we're not actually
providing causal information.
Why is this happening?
And most importantly, what can
we do about what's happening?
Nevertheless, some computer scientists
have actually doubled down.
Not only do we not need causes,
we don't actually really
need doctors either.
So this is my favorite from
Jeff Hinton in 2016 saying,
you know what, just stop
training radiologist.
It's just completely obvious
in five years deep learning
is gonna be able to do better,
it's gonna get more experience.
And then he sort of walked back and said,
well okay, if you're like a radiologist,
you're like the coyote
who's looked over the edge of the cliff
but hasn't looked down
and doesn't know there's
no ground under him.
He acknowledged maybe we
need some radiologists
but we have enough already,
we don't need to train more.
And so, you know, I don't
think any of us want
computers giving us diagnoses,
but even so this idea
that learning from data
and experience is all you need,
we've actually seen that's
totally wrong, right?
And so there've been lots of cases
of radiology has been a really
popular application area
for deep learning and there's
nice really quick cycle
of hype and then the
antidote to the hype of
as we learn deep learning
is better than radiologists.
And then a week later,
actually no it's not.
So this is an example
of one of those papers
where it's trying to predict pneumonia
and then the numbers
on the left are showing
how important these different
areas of the X-ray are.
And then a sort of weird one
is in the upper left you see
there's a one next to portable
because the algorithm
thinks it's really important
that used a portable scanner
and that's gonna help me predict
whether this patient has pneumonia or not.
And so it's using features
that are totally inappropriate,
not useful at all, have nothing to do
with the patient's diagnosis or not.
And that was a mistake that a radiologist
would absolutely never make, right?
A radiologist is not going to look
at that information at all
because they understand which
things are actually meaningful
for the disease or not.
Another fun case was Google Flu.
So Google was using
people's search keywords
to predict cases of the flu,
track cases of the flu over time.
And they were doing it actually better
than the CDC for a while.
So people got very excited.
You can figure out how much
flu is in the area based on,
you know, searching for symptoms
and treatments and things like that.
And then what happened afterwards
was suddenly Google's
predicting twice as many cases
of the flu as there actually were.
And then now we know more
about Google Flu as a failure.
My favorite thing about this
is the quote I showed you
about prediction and not
needing to know how things work
was from a Google employee
after this actually happened.
And so I don't think Google's
fully learned the lesson there
that even if you want predictions,
you're not gonna have a robust prediction
without causal relationships.
You're not gonna be able to predict
when your prediction
is gonna stop working.
We have no idea why search
keywords relate to cases
of the flu you search
based on you, your friends.
Maybe you've heard about Google doing this
and so you search also
that changes your behavior.
We have no idea.
And so even just for prediction,
which has been the thing that
most computer scientists try
to sell you on without causal
relationships we need causes.
Second thing we really
care about is explanation.
I love time series data, so
this is my favorite website.
It pulls lots of time series off the web
and then puts them together.
So if you have any two
non-stationary time series,
they're non-stationary in similar ways,
you can get these really
strong correlations.
A lot of them involve cheese
for some unknown reason.
Actually, I gave a talk and showed this
and one person was like, no,
I think this actually is causal,
they're eating too much cheese
and then they're, you know, falling asleep
and then they're actually die suffocating
because of all the cheese consumption.
And so that was enjoyable.
But we can make these stories, right?
I have another one.
Any two exponential time
series look really similar.
Starbucks stores and autism
cases follow the same trend.
I could also say use of cell phones
and autism cases probably
follow a similar trend, right?
There's nothing causal there,
but because these have
a similar trajectory,
you can make a story but we
don't fully understand them
unless we understand, oh
these are just, you know,
the cause here is time
and they're changing
in similar ways over time.
Control is probably the most
useful and interesting thing.
Sometimes it's linked with explanation.
This was a case where used
simulation to understand
causes of singular events.
And so the bold line shows a
person's glucose over time.
The two rises, the
first one is after a run
and then the later one is after lunch.
But we can go back and ask questions,
what happened if the person
didn't have, didn't go for a run
or didn't have lunch
or had a smaller lunch?
It's really hard if you
imagine just the bold line
and you're a person with
diabetes looking at that,
figuring out why is my glucose
too low right now, right?
To figure out from those two events
you can't really pick it
apart and say, you know,
wasn't too much insulin,
wasn't my run was too long
or too intense, you don't know.
But we can go back with
stipulation and say,
actually in this case it turned out
it was the two events together.
Each one individually wouldn't have led
to glucose that was too low.
It was only the combination
of the two events.
And so now once you have that
information in the future,
you know, this is how I
should change my insulin
or change my activity or
change my lunch, right,
to avoid hypoglycemia.
And so you're much more
able to react to the world
once you have that
information about causes.
So I spent a lot of time arguing
we need causal Relationships,
causes are really important
if you wanna do anything
useful in the world.
I wrote a couple books about that
and then the last few years
I've also come to believe
causes are necessary but insufficient.
And so the last part of
this talk will be about
that insufficient part
and why we need understanding
of human behavior.
So first I wanted to show a few examples
of learning from observation.
And so I like to make things difficult.
I like really hard cases
where we can only observe,
I have no ability to
experiment whatsoever.
I can't even change what gets observed
and can we find some causal relationships.
And so the reason it's interesting is
I was in bioinformatics as a PhD student
and then EHRs came about and
were becoming much more popular
and I thought, oh this is really cool.
We can go back.
We have 20 years of data on people
and see what happened
before they became sick.
You learn very quickly that
you don't have 20 years
of data on everyone and the
number of people is much smaller
and there's lots of complexity.
But for a person really
interested in time series,
it was very exciting time series data.
I'll talk about a couple
other similar cases.
I won't talk as much
about the technical detail
but to, you know, have in your head
what do I mean when I
say causal relationships?
It's not a amazing
network, a graphical model.
My focus is time.
I think time is critical for
intervening in the world.
I think we care a lot about the timing
of the relationships we find.
If you take a medication you really care,
is this going to, you know,
leave my headache in 15
minutes or four hours?
If I just tell you it's gonna help you,
you're probably not gonna
be that satisfied with that.
And a lot of relationships
are complicated.
You have, you know, combinations
of factors, interactions,
you have one thing happening
until something else happens.
And so to me, the natural way
to represent a causal of relationship is
with temporal logic.
That's what the top thing is
saying that vigorous exercise
leads to hyperglycemia in 15 to 40 minutes
and this happens with probability 0.4.
And so that's for me
what a causal relationship looks like.
It has timing, there might be
other stuff on the left side,
it could be multiple factors,
maybe the variables are
continuous, that's fine,
they don't have to be discreet
and there's always a time
window associated with that.
And I also wanna discover
that from the data.
I assume that I know nothing going in.
And how do I find causal relationships?
And so basically we're thinking about
what we're doing in the data is
what we'd wanna do if we could experiment,
is imagine toggling the cause on and off
and seeing how the effect changes.
And so that's essentially
what we're doing is keeping
everything else fixed and
then holding the cause,
changing the cause, whether
it's true or false or it's value
and seeing what happens to the effect.
There's some other details in there,
but that's the basic idea.
And again, there's no Bayesian networks
and anything that looks
like a Bayesian network
later on is not a Bayesian network.
Just can't be vehement enough about that.
Sometimes people think
they're Bayesian networks
and they get really uncomfortable
because there's cycles.
And so I just wanna make sure
you're not uncomfortable.
So the first example is
learning from EHR data.
So this was a really
poor choice of problem.
I decided to work on
congestive heart failure.
And the reason it's a
difficult choice of problem
or a poor choice of problem is
that it's really hard from an EHR
to know who has heart failure.
Heart failure is not like a stroke
where you have this acute dramatic event.
You know, in our data we can say roughly
the time the stroke happened,
it doesn't even make sense
to say when the heart
failure happened, right?
Heart failure is a chronic
progressive disease.
You have the worsening over time,
there's not this key onset time
and then it gets worsened the background
until at some point it's
clinically apparent,
it gets diagnosed.
And so really there's like, you know,
a probability of heart failure over time.
And then at some point it
becomes, you know, discernible.
There's not, you know, a
single piece of evidence
in the record that tells you
if a person has heart failure.
You can look at diagnosis codes,
you can look at medications,
you can look at symptoms.
After you do that, you see
there's a lot of people
who seem to have symptoms
but aren't being treated
or seem to have treatments
but no diagnosis of heart failure
and it becomes very messy.
And so we did that.
We found some ways to figure out
who had heart failure, who didn't.
This was data for about 30,000 people
in rural Pennsylvania, Geisinger.
We applied our methods,
we learned timings from the data.
This is what we find: dx means diagnosis.
And again the effect here
is not actually heart failure, right?
Because we don't know, we have no idea
when heart failure happens,
the effect is the
diagnosis of heart failure.
And what we're finding is these
other things that are known,
hypothyroidism, diabetes,
being overweight,
they're happening maybe a
year and a half to two years
before the diagnosis.
Then it becomes really hard to interpret.
You need a lot of background knowledge.
So blood pressure is a
notoriously noisy measurement
in the electronic health record.
We don't find high blood pressure.
We find being on a medication
for high blood pressure
because that's less noisy and
it's a much better indicator
of whether you have high blood
pressure, the same thing,
urinary symptoms, that's a
symptom of heart failure,
frequent nighttime urination.
And that's what we find is
the most common code here.
And so what happens is
we're finding people,
it's not that the symptom
is causing heart failure,
that'd be crazy.
The symptom is happening
about 8 to 11 months
before the diagnosis of heart failure.
But it's really hard if someone
just gives you the data,
you would have no way to interpret this
and know it's happening.
We repeated this with data from Columbia,
which was much messier.
It was mostly text data.
It's really hard to get
time from text data.
And so we find a lot of
things with medications
because the medications were
stored in a structured way
and it's much easier to find
the person taking insulin
versus they were diagnosed with diabetes.
And so instead of finding the diabetes
or thyroid problems,
we find the medications
for those diseases.
So there were some successes there.
I moved on, I thought well, this was hard
because we don't really
know what's happening
in between the times you see a doctor
but you have, you know, a
couple visits a year maybe
and then what's happening
when you're at home.
Chronic diseases are
interesting because one,
the main things are happening
outside the hospital.
If you have diabetes, your
doctor is not there with you
every time you have a
meal or exercise saying,
here's how much insulin you should take
to adjust for that, right?
You have to figure that out
and you're making decisions
all day long about that.
Also, the data we have is not, you know,
research grade sensors, it's
things in the real world
that become a lot more uncertain.
So just give a sense of that uncertainty.
Key measurement for people
with diabetes is glucose,
it's a blood glucose which
test with a finger stick
or now there are sensors
that can measure glucose,
sort of continuously get
measurement every five minutes.
So, but they're called continuous.
However, the standards for
these devices are pretty lax.
So if you have a value
of 150, maybe it's low,
maybe it's high, we don't really know.
Hypoglycemia.
So glucose it's too low
can be really dangerous.
If your glucose is 70, that's pretty norm,
that's low end of normal.
But we don't know based on the error rates
could be 60, could be 81.
And that's according to the FDA standards.
Studies have shown that a lot of devices
don't actually meet those standards.
And so it's a really challenging problem
for causal inference.
If you wanna think how do I find causes
of hypo or hyperglycemia,
I can't actually trust my measurements.
You know, if your value is 69,
probably it's okay, I don't really know.
So I had a small data set
where we really couldn't
throw away any data
and say we're only going to take
the values we're really certain about.
So we incorporated uncertainty
into our causal inference.
And everything here is
based on it's data-driven.
We're calculating probabilities
in a frequency based manner.
And so I can just wait
my inferences, right?
So I can learn from some values
more strongly than others.
And this is what the data looked like.
We had only 17 people over three days.
So pretty small data.
There were a lot of different sensors,
they were very active,
they went rock climbing,
they did all kinds of other
stuff in their daily life.
Sensors broke.
That's what happens.
And we wanted to find
what are the causes of hyper/hypoglycemia.
And it was only when we
incorporate the uncertainty
that we could find anything.
If we didn't do that, we basically found
if your glucose is high, it stays high.
If it's low, it stays low.
It's true, but not very interesting
as a causal relationship.
But once we incorporated, you
know, what's the probability
that your glucose is high or low
given this value that I've measured,
now we can actually make this finding
that intense activity does lead
to high glucose in 5 to 30 minutes.
So it's exciting.
But this data set was missing
one of the most important things
for understanding glucose,
which is meals we didn't
know anything about that.
They were not recorded or
whether they were recorded
but not timestamped.
And so essentially not recorded,
can't use it if you don't know the timing.
One of the challenges and causal inference
has been often we assume we get data,
we apply our methods to
it, we get some output,
but that means we're starting from scratch
with every data set, right?
Which is not really realistic.
We kind of, we hopefully
learn some things over time.
We know some things
about meals and glucose,
it's actually really complicated.
We don't know everything.
Fat, protein, all these
things affect your glucose
and interact with carbohydrates.
But we thought we can incorporate
some simple information.
And so here we use knowledge of the effect
of meals on glucose.
We use that to reconstruct these meals.
We'll talk about the details.
But the key idea is using that
we actually know something
and then importantly, we
develop ways of figuring out
what our knowledge doesn't apply.
Because you might learn
something from one experiment
and it doesn't apply at
all to another population.
And there we could actually
find these other relationships.
Now we found, oh, moderate
exercise has a different effect
than intense exercise.
We found that actually
exercise causes people
to have a meal afterwards,
which makes sense.
If your glucose is gonna be low
after moderate exercise,
you're gonna compensate with a meal.
And then other methods
didn't find anything.
I could have a whole separate
talk about other methods
that didn't work at all on real data,
but we won't do that today.
And so the key has been it's really hard
to find causal
relationships in these data,
but it's possible with some creativity.
Third application I wanted to mention
is looking at stroke data.
So this is really different
in terms of frequency compared
to the other data sets.
So in the hospital data,
data for 30,000 people
is about the same size as data
for 100 stroke patients,
just if you're talking about this size.
So these are about 100 really
intensively monitored people.
This is the situation
you saw in the picture
of the ICU patient.
Those sensors are measuring
every one to five seconds
the entire time someone's in the ICU.
The measurements depend on the
patient's status of course,
and I have no ability to change that.
We have EEG on the surface of the brain,
EEG within the brain, microdialysis,
physiologic measurements,
but a lot's missing.
And so this is three
patients, X axis is time.
And the Y axis are different variables,
which are different for
the different patients.
The top person you can see
as during their ICU stay,
there's just more
variables over time, right?
As their status changes, the
doctors think other things
are important and maybe
we should measure 'em.
The middle person
this is a variable that's
measured every hour
by a human writing down the value.
And you can see these
aren't evenly spaced, right?
Because it's an ICU, it's
a complex environment,
lots of things are happening
and it's not anyone's priority
to write down this number
exactly every hour on the hour, right?
It's not gonna happen.
Last one, there's huge chunks of time
with all variables missing
because maybe there's a surgery
or procedure, everything's
disconnected for that.
Other times things just
slip out of where they were.
And so if you think of this
in terms of causal inference,
none of this missing data
is missing at random, right?
It's all missing for a reason,
which is generally the
patient's health status
or things that are
happening to the patient
or about the patient.
And so if we ignore that,
then we have a huge problem
with confounding, right?
And so we spent five years dealing
with missing data problems.
How do we reconstruct missing values
when you have all variables
missing at a time point,
when the relationships are
lagged between the variables.
We developed methods
for all of those things.
So it was, we started working
with this data in 2010.
By 2015 we actually got a causal
model that we believed in.
So this is part of the model
and again, not a busy network.
So the cycles are fine.
I just don't know how to
represent temporal relationships
in a satisfying way.
And so there's no time on the graph,
but there's time everywhere.
And some of these relationships
could be positive,
some could be negative.
I'm not showing you any of that.
And the doctors thought there
was this important transition
at 96 hours.
So we just crudely separated the data
in these two time periods,
did our causal inference
for the first period
and then for the second
period we compared them.
And the things to note is one,
there's just more cause
relationships over time,
which was interesting.
And the thing that
doctors cared about a lot
was this TW percent to the bottom,
which represents brain swelling.
And so if your causes
are changing over time,
it starts off with brain
temperature later on.
It's brain oxygenation,
blood flow in the brain,
maybe your interventions also
have to be different over time, right?
If your causes change over time.
So that was super exciting.
Oh, and the numbers are
relate to the number of people
that relationship was found in
because people have
different things measured.
However, this is what the
entire model looked like.
For me, this was five years of work.
I was so excited after this.
This was like we actually did it.
We've solved stroke obviously
and gave this to the doctor,
you're gonna use this
to treat your patients now, right?
I've solved all of your problems.
And he called this unholy mess.
He's German and very blunt.
And I thought, okay, that's not exactly
what I was hoping to hear.
We spent like three
hours going through this.
He had a lot of questions,
why is this not there?
Well it had no variation.
If there's no variation, we
can't find causal relationships
and, you know, why is this there?
Why is that that not there?
And then his questions were, okay,
if heart rate causes this,
what happens if I give this medication?
I said, I have no idea.
Medication's on a variable in the graph
and so I can't tell you
anything about it, right?
Which is the key problem
is everything here is,
you know, the variables we
measure, his questions are
what ifs about interventions, right?
And none of the interventions
are on a variable
and that like do calculus, you know,
turning a variable on and off.
They're all, I have a strategy
where I can maybe change temperature
or, you know, change blood flow,
but I don't have direct
access to that variable
and I couldn't help him at all.
So then after five years, hopefully, yeah,
this was my feeling about that
was maybe I'm the problem, right?
I've been telling everyone,
causal relationships are super important.
We need causal relationships
to do anything.
If you're gonna make
decisions or interventions
or predictions, you need causes.
And then it turns out my
collaborator, who, you know,
literally has his fingers
in people's brains
couldn't use these models.
So starting in about 2017, I wondered,
does this actually help
people make decisions?
And if we look at how we
evaluate our causal models,
we don't evaluate
decision making of course,
or computer scientists,
we evaluate accuracy
and more is better pretty much.
There's different, you
know, different metrics,
but they're all kind of the same thing
and they have the same shared values.
And the value is did you find
more of the causes that are there?
And did you find fewer wrong causes?
And maybe sometimes we care about
how fast your algorithm runs
or how much data it needs,
but those are kind of secondary.
It's really more is better
finding the most complete
model you can possibly find.
And so I thought, okay,
psychologists knows some
things about people.
They've done a lot of work on causality.
This is kind of what it looks like.
Reminds me a little bit
of the Bayesian networks
that I found as a PhD student.
There are these very
constrained setups, right?
They're trying to do controlled studies
and figure out what can
people do interventions
for causal relationships,
in what cases, right?
When can they infer causes?
And so there are all these book detectors
where you put blocks on a
box and see if it makes music
or there's like made up microorganisms.
My favorite is mind reading aliens
probably you have no experience
with mind reading aliens.
So you have to rely totally
on what the researchers tell you, right?
You're not combining this at
all with your past knowledge,
which is really different
from what happened
with my collaborator, right?
He's not looking just at what I told him.
He's thinking, yeah, but
I have this hypothesis
about this relationship,
why isn't that there?
Or what is this other one?
How does that fit into what I know?
And that's what happens when
we get guidance about health
and finance and all these
other things, right?
We're not just taking, you know,
this information about
a vaccine in a vacuum.
We're fitting it in with our prior beliefs
about the disease, vaccines in general,
all this other stuff.
So I started doing decision making studies
where people made everyday choices
and they were a little bit more realistic.
So this was the first one that we did.
We had a student, they have,
they just started college.
They're adjusting to a busy schedule.
She's trying to avoid gaining weight
but also wants to make friends
and leave time for homework and studying.
And so we showed people causal model
or the same model as just
text or no causal model.
And at this point I was still optimistic.
I thought this is like
taking an open book exam.
If I give you the causal model,
even if you already know
the information, you know,
it's like it's reminding you
right of what you already know.
And that's not at all what happened.
And so we found causal
models made things worse.
People consistently made worse choices.
And it didn't matter if
it was a diagram or text,
people made worse choices,
by the causal model.
So that was really disappointing
after all my years spent
trying to find causal models
from really, really difficult data
and also convincing
people that causal models
were really important and useful.
And we looked at everything.
We looked at, you know,
how much time do people spend on it?
Were they ignoring it?
No, they spent longer with it.
We did again, maybe about
four years of interventions
of what if we show people
how little they know.
If we give them like quizzes
or help them reflect on their knowledge,
maybe they'll be more
open to new information
because they'll realize they
actually need the information.
It didn't work at all.
People knew that they
didn't know anything.
They tried to use the
model and they couldn't.
And in all these cases,
people were also doing these questions
about aliens and robots
and things like that.
And they had no problem
in those cases, right?
They were totally fine when
the question was about robots.
But once it was about, you
know, saving for retirement
or managing their diabetes,
suddenly they were doing
terribly on these questions
and also they were losing
confidence as well.
And so we measured how they
felt about their decisions
and they felt worse about their
choices with a causal model.
So it was really quite that.
And so my mental model of how
things were gonna go was this,
at the start I was like, you know,
you have this gap in your knowledge.
I'm coming in with my causal model,
I'm going to slot it right into that gap.
And, you know, problem solved.
And I think it was more
like this, that, you know,
you already have all these beliefs,
I'm giving you information,
it does not fit cleanly
into these other things
and I haven't helped you
figure out how to map it
to what you already know.
And so skipping ahead a few years,
finally we have some positive results.
So we'll end on a good note.
What if we focus people's attention?
And so it wasn't people's willingness
to use the causal model.
It wasn't that they didn't understand
what a causal model means.
They understood that perfectly well.
We think that it was that
they didn't really know
which parts of it to
use or how to combine it
with their existing knowledge.
And so we started doing
studies testing that.
So using either very complex model
or giving people just the
parts that were relevant.
And so in this case, if you think back
to the diagram I showed you before,
you could use that for lots
of different questions.
And that's what we often
try to create, right?
As a general model, you could use it
for many different purposes.
We don't specifically tailor
it to this is one decision
that you're gonna make,
here's the right model for that decision.
But what if we did right?
And so here we're showing
people different parts
of the model depending on the question
that they're answering.
And so that's why there, there
are different models here
and some of them have cycles.
Here the dashed edges are
negative causal relationships
because it was based on a
well-known diagram about obesity
that used that similar format.
That was a very complex model.
But I won't show you that one.
Questions looked very similar.
Again, we have a person,
they have some constraints.
This one, they don't have that much time.
They're concerned about their weight
and they have a few options.
And again, the options
aren't variables, right?
It's not, you know, increase carbohydrates
or increase exercise.
It's what exact strategy
you're going to do,
which is much harder and much,
much more different, right?
So he could do nothing.
He could fast forward through commercials,
he could get takeout or change
up his recipes a little bit.
So finally we had some positive results.
Turns out there was no
difference between the simple
and the complex diagram
and no information,
but simplicity that that
turned out to be the answer.
Giving people just the
information they needed,
putting blinders on them
led to better results.
The interesting thing
is you can also use that
to change people's preferences
in maybe undesirable ways.
And so it's known that
people prefer intervening
on root notes compared to
internal or direct causes.
And so we tested that
with this causal chain.
Seems a bit, you know,
more sensible or if you're,
you have a probabilistic model,
it's mathematically superior
to intervene on the direct cause, right?
So you'd think why not
directly change someone's diet
versus like not watch as
much TV so you're not exposed
to food ads and then
have an unhealthy diet
because of the food ads.
That's sort of indirect and
could fail at different points.
But when we show people this model,
then in this simple model,
they picked the food ads more.
And so you do have to be careful
how you simplify the model.
But we expanded beyond health.
We tried lots of
different decision making.
So picking a college, lowering
your carbon footprint,
mental health, all these different cases.
And the exciting news was
we found the exact same
thing in every domain.
Simple models helped.
We showed if you just
highlight the relevant path,
so make an orange, draw
attention to it, that works.
So you don't have to just, you
know, hide the whole model,
but you have to show people
what part of the model is.
So I started wondering, you know,
is there some level of
complexity that's right?
You know, maybe there's something
in between these like really big models
and really small one and tested.
What if we just add in
a little bit of extra,
couple extra nodes, couple extra edges.
No, that was not helpful at all.
And the results were basically the same
as if you give people a
completely complicated model.
And so any extra information
gives you an opportunity
to overthink basically.
And so if you think of like
when you give your students
exams and they have questions
during the test about a question
that you think was maybe very easy,
they're overthinking, right?
I have these questions, I
gave an exam last spring
and the easiest possible question
people had the most questions
about for me during the exam.
And they're like, well what about this?
Or should I, you know, like
rely on my knowledge of calculus
and all that?
And like, I'm like, no, it really is.
Just take it at face value.
It's as simple as you think it is.
And, you know, as you know more,
you have more opportunity
to overthink, right?
And so leaving any possibility
for that, people start.
And we've done other studies
where people describe
their decision making
process and they add in
so much extra stuff
that's not in the model.
They talk about, you know,
their preferences about medications.
It's really hard to take medications.
Maybe they should start
with this, you know,
if they develop a routine
and they get a dog
and they walk the dog,
then this'll happen.
And then that'll solve
their blood pressure, right?
And so that's why you would
don't have the opportunity
to do that
when the questions about
aliens and robots, right?
There's no potential for like coming up
with these really convoluted stories.
Still, you might think like, you know,
you have a PhD probably you know yourself,
you like getting a lot of information,
you would do better than
people in the studies,
if I just let you choose how
much information you want.
And so we tested that, right?
Instead of randomizing
people, let them choose
and let them choose for each question.
And so they would see here's
what all these types of
information look like
and your next question's going
to be about retirement or finances.
How much information do you want?
So a good fraction of people
pick the simple diagram,
which is the best choice.
So that was good news.
However, people don't know
how much information they need
and people who think they need
the most complicated information
or no information at all
are not right.
Those numbers are almost exactly the same
as when we randomized people
and simple diagrams, again,
were still had the highest accuracy.
And then we had other data that was fun.
It turned out that women did better
in all information conditions than men.
Also people with less
education did better.
Again, with the overthinking,
the more you know, the
more opportunity you have
to like come up with
all these extra things,
all these extra ideas add information
that's just not relevant
and not useful at all
to the diagram.
But again, we were
excited that after, again,
about five years, finally
we made causal models
better than nothing, which
was really depressing
for giving talks was just,
and for a while it was,
we can make causal models
as good as nothing but not better.
So this was a nice improvement.
But going back to the beginning,
so I've changed my tune a little bit
that completeness is not the right thing
to value in causal models, right?
It might be helpful for, you
know, scientific accuracy
and understanding, but if we really care
about decision making or
interventions, that's not,
that's not what we need, right?
And so we need new ways of
thinking about what is utility
for a causal model.
Here, we didn't take into
account people's decision context
how much time they have,
what their background is.
We didn't do any of that.
And so there's a lot of other
stuff to be explored there.
Also, other things I didn't
mention fund dirty laundry.
I didn't tell you how I find variables.
I don't know what a variable is.
I have no idea how to tell you
what the right variables
are for your problem.
But everything, they're really important
and all guarantees are relative
to having the right variables
and so get it right.
Our assumptions are almost
never true, you know?
And so we can't guarantee
that anything is causal
because all the assumptions
we need to make are false.
I also have no idea how much data I need.
You know, there's no
power analysis whatsoever.
More is probably better,
but we don't know.
It's, you know, I can sometimes tell you
after the fact that I
didn't have enough data,
but I can't tell you proactively
here's how much you need
to collect to find a causal model.
And so there's huge gaps in
finding causal models from data,
even though I've shown
you some success stories.
So, and there and just think
all the different collaborators
that were involved in this work.
Thanks.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much for giving
us the unvarnished truth
about causal modeling.
So I just want to invite
anyone who wants to speak
to just press the button on the microphone
and speak up.
I'm happy to start with
the first question.
So I was really curious, how are you,
so in this,
in the process of making
those causal change,
are you marginalizing
over prior information
that people have
or is prior information
is that really not part
of the whole scheme?
- We haven't incorporated like
individual's prior knowledge.
We don't know.
We've done other studies trying
to just quantify someone's
degree of knowledge
about a problem, but haven't used that.
We haven't made predictions, for example,
about like what would someone choose.
We've done other work looking at
where we got people's mental models.
Another fun project is
how do you know you got someone's
mental model accurately?
How do you evaluate mental models?
That's been been fun.
But mostly what we found there was
we couldn't change people's mental models.
They had the same mental model
before and before and after.
Yeah.
- David, then Sean and then Eduardo.
- Just very briefly, that
was really fascinating.
I have lots of questions.
For the last main part of the presentation
where simple models were
better all around, right?
That's what I took at
least the message to be.
Can you say a bit more?
If I follow correctly,
your team was trying to,
at least in some of these instances,
trying to build a more complete model
and then work from there to simplify
or am I missing, am I forgetting?
- Well, we're working to,
on all the health data,
the goal was find all the causal
relationships in the data.
In the simple models case,
we started with models
that were in the literature
on all these different topics
and then simplified them for
these different decisions.
- So I guess, so my, my question really is
were there rules or strategies
or rules of thumb in how your
team made the simplification?
I can imagine simplifying
in all kinds of ways
and some simplifications
might actually be less
helpful than others.
- Yeah.
- If there's a complete,
a more complete model available,
what's the decision tree
to say this is the simple model,
I'll now put in front of my people
and this will be more
helpful or less helpful
for what they need to do?
- That's a great question.
For this, the simplification
was very simple.
The simplification was
literally just showing the paths
in the model that were
relevant for that decision.
And so we showed, if we
know for everything here,
there was a right answer essentially,
which is another topic
people sometimes are uncomfortable with.
But if you think like what's the node
that your answer should be targeting?
What are the paths from
that to the effect?
And that's what we showed people.
But I think an interesting idea is about
how you abstract the model, right?
And I think that's sort of
what you're getting at is like
how do you collapse some of
these paths into other processes
or things like that.
Here I, yeah, there
we just didn't have the
ability to do that for this.
I think that's a future
sort of future topic of
how would you create those automatically.
I think that's challenging,
but if you have them in some
in particular domains, it'd
be interesting to test them.
Yeah.
- Sean.
- Your conclusions seem
to jive very closely
with the conclusions of fast
and frugal heuristics research
program of Gerd Gigerenzer
and his research group
at Max Planck Berlin.
Is that a reasonable interpretation?
- Yeah, it's not inconsistent with that.
And it's also similar
to I think what we find
with the people with more education
and more knowledge, right?
It's like when you ask the,
you know, German students
about capitals in the US they, you know,
pick the cities they've heard of, right?
Whereas we ask American students,
they're like overthinking
and thinking like, oh, I don't know,
maybe it's a trick question.
It's not, you know, I can't
think of any capitals now,
but San Antonio or whatever.
I dunno what the capital of Texas is.
But anyway, it's similar
to that when we have people
with background knowledge
and people with that,
we've done other studies
where people have varying
degrees of background knowledge
and you see people without
take the diagrams much more
at face value.
- Eduardo.
- Thank you. Fascinating.
I took so many notes of
things that relate to
what I'll be talking tomorrow.
I have a very concrete question
that I hope will be easy
to address and a second one
that I just wanna engage your thoughts.
The first one is, did you say
that blood pressure data are
a mess in the digital records?
Because as a patient, if there's one thing
that I would imagine shouldn't be hard
to keep track is numbers.
- It's not that it's hard
to keep track of,
it's hard to keep track of most things.
I mean, so if you wanna
talk about a real mess,
we didn't use race and ethnicity
because the data on that is too messy.
It's not stored in a standardized way.
And also because of copy and paste errors,
you find errors in the same record
where race is changing over time
and you think, I don't know
what the correct value is.
The blood pressure wasn't that,
it wasn't that we
couldn't extract the data.
We could.
It's that if you like think
what happens when you go
to your primary care doctor
and they check your blood
pressure, there's time pressure,
you're stressed out, right?
It's just a very noisy measurement.
And so it's measurement
itself is problematic.
Not the storage.
That was a lot of other variables.
- And the other one that relates
to what we were discussing
before that in your field
discipline different from mine,
different from mine, you
have to make decisions
or at least you're informing
people who make decisions.
And towards the end you are referring
to how we don't really
have power analysis tools
for causal inference.
But what I noticed if I followed you well,
that for very, very different effect sizes
that you are reporting in
the percentage of responses
to the questionnaires
or the tests you did,
you are relying on
statistical significance.
But it seemed to me if I
followed it well that it would,
there's probably very, very
clear sample size issue there
because very, very small
effect sizes for the percentage
of respondents were deemed significant,
therefore, made informed a decision.
And towards the end, some
of those much bigger,
I'm talking 10, 15%
difference in response rate
were considered not significant.
And I wonder how you're
connecting this kind of,
if we're gonna rely on
statistical inference,
we may end up with making
unwarranted recommendations
on what to do.
- So, well there are two parts.
So for the psychology
studies and decision making,
we can do power analysis
and we have some idea
of the effects size and how
much, it's when I'm trying
to learn a causal model from data
and the model might be complicated
and there's relationships
over time as all these have,
there's no way to figure out
how many observations do you need?
I don't know.
It probably depends on the
complexity of the structure.
I don't know.
We often don't even know
what's the right level
of time granularity,
what's the right sampling rate,
how often, how fast are things changing?
So we'd know how to measure them.
I couldn't tell you, you know,
how many observations
do I need of, you know,
if I have 10 variables or
50 variables, you know,
with certain density or
whatever in the causal model,
I can't tell you how
many observations I need
to be confident in the causal model.
Whereas like for the psychology studies,
we can do that obviously
and do a paralysis there.
That was for the appointments
for a different part.
- [Priya] One final question before we-
- [Man] So two questions.
So one is, do you consider a possibility
when you do your research
that the real cause is not
on the list even more so it's not known.
I mean in the history of medicine
there are plenty examples of this.
And the second one I was
wondering if you ever tried
to convince a teenager
say to take vitamins
because they prevent, you
know, respiratory disease
or, I mean when I was buying a house,
the building inspector told
me that people buy the house
and this way and he was very experienced.
They look at it, they like it or not.
And then in retrospect they explain why,
because I think, you know,
the psychology part of it,
this would explain why, you know,
playing with aliens is perfectly
explainable and modelable,
but making decisions,
it is very different.
The more they are life,
you know, threatening,
the more it is.
- Sorry, I forgot the first part now.
- [Man] Ah, yeah, because
you, yeah, the first part,
the most interesting and most,
you know, practical medicine.
- Yeah.
- is the variable, you know,
peptic ulcer, it was considered
to be psychosomatic disease
and you can imagine how many
models you can make on that,
but it turned out to be
a bacterial infection.
But bacterial were not on the list.
- No, it's a huge problem.
And I mean in these cases
I can't do anything about it, right?
In the hospital data, I
can't change what's measured.
I have some studies where I can,
and I've collected data during pregnancy
looking at stress and nutrition.
I'm sure there are gaps.
And then we also have things
that we know are probably causal
but are too expensive to measure
and we can't measure them.
- [Man] But I mean, is there a possibility
to see that the list that
you can see is incomplete is
by itself would be a big finding?
Say these variables do not explain.
- Yeah, sure.
And there are methods that purport
to find unmeasured variables.
Though none have worked well
in the test that I've had.
I don't, we can't confidently do that,
I don't think personally.
And then on the second part,
I haven't convinced teenagers of anything,
but I did convince a student in my class
and his father to quit smoking
because I use so many causal
examples about smoking.
And so that's my one
success story of being able
to convince people to make a
decision from a causal model.
- [Priya] Thank you so
much again, Samantha.